yes I'm here
promise you'll never forget about me
yes of course
probably you'll take care of her little
great love her
promise me you'll stay strong for her
yes yes promise me you'll never sleep
with another woman
I promise me you'll take care of mr. big
fluffy tail yes yes yes yes that can be
the most loved cat and that you won't
look at porn yes second ticka ticka
ticka - get it - get it - get it
check no pornography mr. Brown says what
is that a yes
Oh battle buddy why are washing a girl
you love me right yes I love you yes go
we're soul mates right yes so you will
never ever ever think of someone else
while masturbating right message
received
I don't understand is that a yes yell
comprende is that a promise your request
has been filed
say you promise forget a bar I need to
hear you say it
I say I promise you promise you you
promise say it
no air quotes say it I promise
I promise what are you promising like
she said we at least promised to go see
my mom every day
so zero pornography done I like that
nurse fix my wife know about you
you